hello welcome to this video playing
October 11 haha who is that said some
kind of two new account huh really new
account okay so check some a Bogle kind
of opening I wanted to I think I'm going
c5 here check your here black has a
really am playing for us a good
development that is giving up the bishop
pair but it's got a very decent
development yeah this is an interesting
moment I think if i'm not mistaken black
now can castle or play Bishop f3 which
is an interesting move i don't remember
i think i am actually give both in my
book as playable so what about this here
rook c8 and let's just go up c 8
yeah development is really really good
but why just got to bishops and no
particular weakness in the position
night f5 let's go tonight a five attacks
the sea pond i also have d5 ideas okay
an IT form is also an hour an idea okay
so there anything I mean wrong with that
I don't think so can go nite be 700 96
both look okay yeah let's go might be
somewhere it's a simple way to play
okay 95 or 96 simply a 96 I guess yeah
it's not a very exciting line I have to
admit that it's really very equal
28 and King fhg 7 yeah it's not very
exciting but like ultimately just equal
i see'em so these six now or maybe d 6
and then night over 285 this is actually
maybe something that I mean not not that
I'm better but i can try to look at the
be three Pawn a little bit at least so
going here so like d5 now or is that bad
maybe I'm maybe let's prevent I'd be
fire for a mode and see what is doing t5
no it's not a good idea rly does he want
to play you fall really maybe yep so if
I was thinking if five and then maybe be
five but
set ambitious too ambitious probably yes
maybe that's too ambitious I can try to
go with to be seven and maybe then e 5
and b5
this one okay interesting if I go e5c to
now this is probably but maybe that's a
bit risky I don't know so trying to
maybe prepare before even it's jumping
in is that wrong I don't know that
before 96 I have this now and then be
five hmm something wrong with my
position not sure night night III 95 is
this a problem i have night before
though k
okay night before see going for night c4
here I don't know it doesn't do that
much I think night c4 I can go rook c6
to cover t6 and maybe go here now even
though I try to play quickly somehow i'm
down on time again
hmm I can go over to you for now here
right when we're missing a check tiger I
don't know b3 also hang so let's go here
maybe it just goes before here I don't
know I take it back to blow well not in
good shape anyway but the position is
good I think v3 just seems to drop him
so time are smooth here take stuff keep
it simple style Lucas is six years but I
can win the eep on shattuck so you can
do that and now go group here but the
pawns will be quick chatter central
pawns
so let's check there is there some rook
a to e well III root k 8 it was not
working but maybe just here and then
king e 5 d 5 and so on to stay on that
pawn okay that's not so easy actually
hmm not a good idea anyway you have to
play so
yeah King doesn't really he'll on the
right my time
so now the upon can be pushed can go to
f2 that's a good way to hide the king
check what for and sometime yeah tough
endgame really tough endgame yeah i
think it was really equal I mean this
kind of position often looks a bit
awkward for black but quite often you
can just trade things and go with the
King on his 737 and then it kind of
candle evaporates I don't know if he
could have done something much better
here around here of course he doesn't
have to lose that's clear but not sure
about a 4 though I think yeah I'm
definitely all right my king is more
active doing something at least but it
still should be all pretty much equal
here and now okay the computer actually
just a computer just sees that I'm
threatening a rootsy for hmm that's a
pretty good pretty good point something
like this is just just awful yeah okay
this is also good but not as good no
tags but it is pretty good yeah it's
also minus one position the way I played
it oh no Luke c6 is bad uh-huh look at
d5 is much stronger or with the aid no
no I didn't didn't see that one really i
know i'm winning okay one wasn't was a
mistake
even though I even though I wasn't that
clearly winning in the game okay this is
a mistake hmm okay fire okay because I'm
threatening okay to this very important
he doesn't really have any active move
now yeah that's much stronger yeah
that's much stronger check check even
though I mean the engine still gives me
a win it might be might be but the other
the other continuation was was a lot
term was a lot simpler now might still
be a winner okay well thanks for
watching